We begin with a rare
attack on Russian soil.
Two groups of pro-Ukrainian Russian
fighters
known as Freedom of Russian Legion
and Russian volunteer corps
say they liberated a settlement
in the Belgorod region,
which sits along the border with Ukraine.
The attack left
eight people injured
and a number of buildings damage
from shelling.
Ukrainian officials
insisting neither group is directly
linked to the government in Kiev
and say both are acting independently.
A spokesman for the Kremlin
says security forces are working to find
what he called a sabotage
and reconnaissance group
and claims
the attack was meant to divert attention
away from Russian forces
claiming victory
in the battle for the eastern
Ukrainian city of Mount over the weekend.
The head of the Russian mercenary group
Sana claimed
his fighters had taken the city
and would hand it over
to the Russian military on Thursday.
More details now from CNN's Fred Pleitgen
who
saw a
rude awakening for Russians
in the border area with Ukraine.
Gunfire and explosions
as two groups
known as the Free Russia Legion
and the Russian volunteer Corps.
Russians fighting for Ukraine
said they captured one village
and entered
another in the Belgorod region.
Logical to the Kremlin.
British Law Review published today.
It's time for everyone
to take responsibility for their future.
One of the leaders says
it's time
to put an end
to the Kremlin's dictatorship.
We teach these tips.
Be sure to check your Kiev
acknowledges the Free Russia Legion
are part of Ukraine's security forces,
but says Ukraine has nothing to do
with the incursion into Russia.
Putin's spokesman irate
The purpose of the Ukrainian sabotage
in the Belgorod region
is to divert attention from the situation
in the Bermuda direction, he said.
The raid spoils
what was supposed to be Russia's
big victory lap.
Flanked by his mercenaries,
Wagner boss
Yevgeny Prigozhin,
claiming to have taken all of Bermuda
this weekend up all year, but do not.
Today, at noon at 12:00,
Bermuda has been fully captured, he said.
There is, but you are sure.
Shortly after Russian
social media channels
filling with providing their propaganda,
mercenaries screaming
victory and celebrating
with champagne showers use Moscow's.
But Ukraine's deputy
defense minister
quick to deny the Russian claims.
One of our nation was brewing.
The Ukrainian armed forces
retain control
of certain industrial facilities
and private houses
in the southwestern area.
From the air and from the ground.
Obama looks apocalyptic.
Any strategic value
the town may have had
for the Kremlin laid to waste
Ukraine's forces
are already fighting back,
making what they say
have been significant gains.
North and south of Bermuda,
taking swathes of land back quickly
to Moscow.
Bermuda was supposed to be both strategic
and symbolic
for Russia and its fight
for control of east Ukraine.
But Wagner says their forces
will withdraw on May 25th
after months of ferocious
fighting and countless dead.
The city will be placed
under Russian military control,
whose commanders have done
more withdrawing than advancing recently.
Liam Collins is a retired U.S.
Army colonel who's now a permanent member
of the Council on Foreign Relations.
He's also the coauthor of Understanding
Urban Warfare.
Thank you for joining us.
You're welcome.
So there have been similar,
if not more limited small attacks
carried out by these pro-Ukrainian,
anti-Putin, Russian fighters.
But is this one the more recent one?
Is it significant?
And is it
a step up from previous attacks?
And how serious should they be taken?
When a spokesman tells CNN
they want to, quote,
liberate our motherland
from the tyranny of Putin?
Yeah.
In terms of the conflict in Ukraine
is not going
to significantly impact
the tactical
or the operational fight there.
But in terms of.
Right.
Russia,
I think it is somewhat significant.
I mean, this is a sizable attack
by Russian citizens on Russian territory.
So Putin doesn't
have the firm grip of his populace.
They would like the world to believe.
But until they can repeat this
and demonstrate
that they're able to do this repeatedly,
then it's
not really going to impact the fight.
They've got to do it
repeatedly for Russia
to divert
combat forces
from Ukraine to their border.
Yeah, well, guess what?
There may be trouble
brewing at home for Putin.
There is victory for him,
at least in name.
In Ukraine, the battle for Back Moot,
which began
almost a year ago with Moscow,
failed to take Kiev
ramped up back in August.
So I assuming for a time
that there is some strategic value
to back.
Does Putin have the manpower,
the resources to use that city
to try and move
Russian forces further into
the Donetsk region?
No, I mean, absolutely not.
I mean, this is a city
that really has little tactical
and no strategic value.
No doubt
Putin will try to sell this as a win,
but I don't think
his own populace believes
that it's the success
that they're trying to sell it has.
And if you look at it, really, it's
an unmitigated disaster for the Russians.
Right.
As you mentioned,
it took them ten months of heavy fighting
just to take this really small city.
A little tactical value in that process.
Right.
Lost tens,
probably hundreds
maybe thousands of soldiers
at the expense of great ammunition
that's not easily replaced.
So really,
I mean, their ability
to launch and move forward from this is
is very debatable
based on how much it took
just to take this
and how long it took to take it.
I want you to listen
to the Ukrainian president.
He was taking questions from reporters
over the weekend of the G7 summit
Here is
is the president
is letting these governments
do in Ukraine's hands.
The Russians say they take about one
I think.
No,
but you have to
understand that there is nothing.
They destroyed everything.
There are no buildings.
It's a bit it's tragedy.
But for today,
the moment is only in our pass.
Yeah.
There's nothing really left of the city
which seems of any value.
And maybe in Zelensky's Heart.
But will the Ukrainians now
try and actually retake that mood?
Is there any value for that?
Or will they just sort of focus
on this counteroffensive?
Yeah, I mean, Ukraine
shown throughout the war,
I mean, they will attack at the time
and place of their choosing
because they are a much smaller military
and do that very effectively.
So they defend where they can
they give up territory where they must
to preserve combat power,
to fight another day.
And they've done
that effectively throughout so
they won't retake
what is left of Baku and less. Right.
They feel that there's is a strategic
position to do that.
But I wouldn't expect them to do that
because I think they're going
to launch the counteroffensive
in other locations
where the Russians are,
where their combat power is not masked.
And over the weekend, you giving figures
in the head of the Wagner
mercenary group,
he claimed victory in Buchmann.
I want you to listen
to part of what he said,
and he begins here addressing
Ukrainian soldiers. Here he is
fed what's advisedly without sarcasm.
Your guys fought bravely, fought well.
And if you follow this path,
then you can become the second army
in the world.
Of course,
after the most powerful army
in the world, that is Wagner PMC.
Today, when you see Biden
kiss him on the top of the head,
say hello for me.
It's notable
he did not say the Russian military
as being the best in the world,
but rather his mercenary group.
But if this is in fact,
not a strategic win,
but instead a political win,
then is it
a political win for operation
or for Putin?
Yeah.
Again, I would be hard
if all this is a political win
for Putin at all.
If anything, it's for promotion.
He could try to sell it as a win.
But then again,
this just shows the dysfunction
in the Russian military
that you have this
private army that arguably fights
better than the Russian military
and all that, all the conflict
that's causing with him and the generals.
And so it really shows the lack of unity
among the the Russian command
and also progressive
seems to be using this
as some kind of springboard
to set himself up
as the heir apparent to Putin.
Is that how it's being read?
I mean, that's
how a lot of people
are interpreting this.
Of course,
that's a fine line
to try to set yourself
up, as is heir
apparent versus a political rival.
And so he's got to walk that fine line
because a lot of rivals may not
may not live to be a rival.
Good point to finish on, Colonel.
Thank you so much for being with us.
We appreciate your time.